let's continue our discussion of the
desperation
from the trump campaign the president is
now so desperate
that he's holding three rallies per day
in the middle of a 100-year pandemic
yesterday holding rallies in allentown
pennsylvania
lititz pennsylvania that sounds weird
but i guess i
maybe it's lightits i'm not i hope i'm
not mispronouncing that
and martinsburg pennsylvania all three
of them in pennsylvania that i can tell
you with full pronunciation certainty
i'm not going to go through all of these
rallies with you i'm going to go through
some elements
they are completely dystopian
authoritarian nightmares
the likes of which we actually have
never seen before in american history
we've seen stuff like this in other
parts of the world particularly
in the 20th century but we've not seen
this type of stuff in america
i'm going to go through just a few
highlights to give you an overall sense
of how much of an emergency it is to
remove this man
starting in allentown pennsylvania
yesterday morning donald trump
who has continued to say foreign leaders
want biden to win
because trump is so tough on them now
trump is just making up conversations
claiming a foreign leader said joe biden
would sleep all the time if he were
president take a listen to this
police are elected they will delay the
vaccine delay therapies prolong the
pandemic
close your schools your schools have to
open and shut down our country
god doesn't have a clue this guy doesn't
have a clue have you seen what this
i mean he we can't play with the country
the only thing i can tell you for sure
president xi from china president putin
from russia
kim jong-un north korea and i could name
40 others
their sharpest attack
they don't want to deal with sleepy jail
one of them said to me one of the
leaders said well i hope you win because
we don't want to deal with somebody that
sleeps
all the time do you believe that no he
just announced the lid
well no you know now that you mention it
i don't believe that that conversation
happened i don't think it did
this is really interesting trump did the
thing yesterday
he used to do this back in 2016. he
pulled out a piece of paper out of his
jacket pocket
where he reads polling numbers and trump
is trying to push back on polls that
show him losing the election
but he's doing it by bragging about his
leads
in places like utah and west virginia
i'll tell you why this is interesting in
a moment
in montana we're so far up they don't
even they shouldn't even have the
election
likewise in utah so far up
we're plus 12 plus 15.
[Applause]
and in west virginia with 20 up 20
points up
these are just came out they came out
today if you are a republican incumbent
president and you're bragging about
polling in utah and west virginia
you are in trouble you are in trouble if
in order to have
good numbers you are even mentioning
utah and virginia two states that
because they are so red
are irrelevant to the electoral college
process in practice they're not
irrelevant
they're irrelevant because their results
are not in question the election doesn't
hinge on them and trump is saying
i'm doing great in utah i'm doing great
in west virginia
very troubling sign trump continuing his
complete rage against wind power he
seems to believe that
if there's wind power if it's not windy
out you can't watch tv
no air conditioning in the summer no
heat during the winter
and no electricity during peak hours
let's watch
president trump on television i'm sorry
we won't be able to do it
the wind isn't blowing today darling we
won't be there
and part of the tragedy is that the
crowd
seems to also think that's how wind
power works if it isn't windy you can't
watch tv
if it's not windy you can't toast your
bread in that moment
complete misunderstanding deliberate
ignorance we may never know then trump
moving on from allentown pennsylvania to
latits pennsylvania trump struggling to
say
extremist i guess this is extremist and
trump
just struggling to speak by rally number
two
i'm keeping the terrorist jihadist and
violent experiments
those terrible extremists the hell out
of our country if that's okay
trump fans then starting a lock him up
chant
towards hunter biden lock up hillary
lock up joe biden lock up the biden's
lock up
hunter biden the state is supposed to
ask us and they weren't going to
but we told him i'm sorry where's hunter
where is hunter he's he's making
he's he's trying to make a deal with a
foreign country to pay him 10 million
where's hunter remember the t-shirt
where's hunter i was right
thank you very much for that squares
this can only happen in pennsylvania
right
i was here for school
[Applause]
the party claiming to be for the
constitution
for law and order for due process
regularly demanding the imprisonment
without due process
of random people who haven't even been
accused of crimes
law and order right constitutional
conservatives
trump then going back to the vaccine
saying any sec
momentarily we're going to have it he
might maybe he'll even announce it at a
rally today
ends the pandemic which is ending with
or without and we have the vaccines
they're going to be very
nobody would have them it would be years
before you had him what i did with fda
and fda's been terrific but it was
called a slightly speedier process okay
and totally safe we will have the
vaccine like
momentarily and we're all set to
distribute it before the end of the year
maybe
substantially before but it's going good
but we are going to get ourselves back
to normal life i said normally
where we were seven months ago so as we
have heard
from trump many times we were expecting
a vaccine approval
early october mid-october late october
before the election we were expecting
people
according to trump to start getting the
vaccine before the election
not happening not happening and uh by
any reasonable
sense from our actual public health
experts
if we are lucky if things go i don't
want to say luck but if things go
perfectly
we hopefully will have some people
starting to get vaccinated by the end of
this year
then on from latits pennsylvania to
martinsburg pennsylvania trump
criticizing barack obama
for having a small crowd today obama
didn't do any events today which was
yesterday it doesn't matter
it's all fiction here it's really
something right did you see the crowd
that president obama had today
nobody nobody showed up i thought they'd
have a little crowd didn't quite have a
crowd like this
no nobody showed up they said he's going
to start campaigning i said who
barack hussein obama i said oh i said is
that good or bad
because you know he campaigned harder
than hillary the last time how did that
work out it didn't work out
and then while bashing joe biden this is
funny
trump gets confused and says biden is
going to give you the biggest tax cut in
the history of the country
just like maybe a moment of clarity
or just trump confused about what he
wants to say the largest tax cut in
history this is the craziest campaign
right so all my life i watch politicians
running they always say
we are going to cut your taxes right
we are going to cut your i got a guy
running now
who sort of shot he goes we
will raise your taxes i say what the
hell
i said did he just say that yeah he's
going to give you the biggest tax cut
in the history of our country yeah i got
confused watching it live
but biden's plan i mean the funny thing
is biden's plan
actually is a tax cut for the bottom 95
percent of americans
and attacks hike for the top five
percent of income earners
uh unclear what trump meant to say is
trump confused that he accidentally tell
the truth
you never know with this guy and then
donald trump again
incoherent on mexico paying for the wall
which they did but don't have to do
because it's built
but they paid for it who knows what the
hell he's talking about
and mexico is paying for the wall by the
way in case you had any questions that's
the other thing
so now they know it's built then they
said but mexico will not be paying for i
said no no mexico is paying for the wall
okay but
they'll figure that out very soon
they'll confiscate
again a total lie the truth is there is
no wall i think they've added about 10
miles
as part of a wall repair program there
is no wall
trump promised the wall across the
entire border by the end of his first
term there's no wall there
okay and mexico has paid for nothing
there's no
toll on people coming into the united
states from
none of it is true and then just as a
sort of
mildly xenophobic uh icing on the cake
trump now regularly at rallies referring
to the former president as barack
hussein obama this is a common trope
hussein hussein hussein hussein
sounds like an arab right this is the
idea of trump repeating it
[Applause]
and part of that was that barack hussein
obama
allowed me to have 142. that's become a
new staple of these rallies in the last
couple of weeks
authoritarian nightmare three more
rallies today
we may cover some of them live barack
obama will also be rallying for joe
biden this week and i plan to cover
those
and we will have more coverage of this
authoritarian nightmare
on the show's instagram page if you are
on instagram
follow the show at david pakman show and
follow me
at david.pakman privacy.com is one of
our sponsors and they're giving you five
dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set spending
limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy dot com
slash pacman